[Music]
so we live in a very scary time where
our private information is constantly
being stolen or leaked to the world so i
thought i'd get ahead of that threat by
having someone i know come on and reveal
a secret about me before they can do it
in a segment we call petey leaks
hey it's pd weeks
uh so here's one of our writers jamie
lee jamie lee everybody
yeah yeah don't look at the cards i
don't want to look at the cards okay
i'll just look at you okay cool we can't
we can't stress enough uh that p does
not know
what i'm about to say true true dat
that's true okay
so yeah my name is jamie liam a writer
for the show and uh fun fact many years
ago pete and i dated for a little while
that is true
yes so
bye no
that's the weird fact
jamie i knew that i was there the whole
time
okay so um this
okay so this one time i was over at
pete's house and i walked by the
bathroom and pete was sitting on the
toilet with the bathroom door open and i
said
gross and he said
no no no no no don't worry i'm just sit
down peeing
[Applause]
you know
like that's way less gross this
literally is pd leaks like
you know what i'm not ashamed why should
women have all the the comfort and
luxury
all right i have to stand there like a
patrolman on watch
i'm gonna sit down i'm gonna sit down
i'm reclaiming the sit down fee for the
dudes no shame i like it
[Music]